tu m'expliqueras quand même mais j'avais
un boulot monstrueux ce week-end moi on
dirait que ça pouvait pas attendre de
rencontrer des parents c'est tout
et comme ça subitement
on regarde si pons
[Musique]
fransat white fouleront pas je te
promets je t'expliquerai c'est quoi ta
tour magne quoi là dedans je
t'expliquerai prend ce paquet c'est
compliqué car c'est quoi ce truc soir je
vous demandais de sortir du véhicule
bien sûr
la demoiselle là quelque chose sur elle
ou doit aussi procéder à une fouille
voilà et vous comptiez faire quoi avec
ça
je la
je sais à quel point j'ai été un boulet
jusqu'à présent la glande à la maison
ils travaillent la nuit tout ça
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de me reprendre
en main de devenir adulte j'ai envie de
rencontrer tes parents je vais me marier
avec toi lola est ce que tu veux
m'épouser s'agit crois pas tu allais me
balance on explique
[Musique]